Phoenix persönlich
wohl niemand hat am 24 Februar beim
Beginn des Krieges gegen die Ukraine die
Folgen einschätzen können wir alle sind
überrascht wie sich dieser Krieg
ausgeweitet hat und vor allen Dingen
auch wie stark wir selber davon
betroffen sind freue mich sehr über
meinen Gast voraus Strategie und
militärexpertin haben Sie das auch so
eingeschätzt wie der sagen wir mal
normal Bürger die normalbürgerin die
überrascht ist was da passiert ist und
dass der Krieg so lange dauert
[Musik]
meistens im ganz kleinen Kreis
entschieden das heißt Sie können nicht
so richtig vorhersehen was und warum
liegt jetzt genau den Schalter um und
das dritte ist natürlich Krieg ist per
See war es was was Geheimnis ist also
sie werden natürlich nie so richtig da
offen kommunizieren darüber damit eben
die Gegenseite nicht weiß was sie
vorhaben die Amerikaner die im Oktober
letzten Jahres eben schon davor gewarnt
haben die der Grund der Warnung war sie
haben gedacht dass man davon Russland
dass man dadurch Russland davon abhalten
kann überhaupt in den Krieg zu ziehen
indem man es offen legt ne also ich
glaube es ist einfach das Phänomen Krieg
an sich was schwer vorherzusehen ist
wann eine ausbricht wir sich entwickelt
das ist strukturell bedingt wenn wir
jetzt alle mehr oder weniger das Gefühl
zumindest haben da ist etwas passiert
was wir nicht für Möglichkeiten haben
und
das ist viel länger was auch uns selber
betrifft an Folgen als wir eingeschätzt
haben worin haben Sie sich geirrt
ich würde sagen ich habe mich ich habe
mich glaube ich geirrt in auch in
unserer europäischen Reaktion und nicht
nur ich sondern Putin auch wenn Sie sich
erinnern 2014 der Angriff auf die Creme
oder die Invasion der Krimi die
Besatzung die Europäer haben damals
relativ verhalten reagiert also
politisch stark aber militärisch
strategisch eigentlich gab es da keine
Reaktion und ich meine was wir jetzt
gesehen haben über das ganze Jahr die
Mobilisierung militäre finanziell
politisch auf eine Ebene wie man
eigentlich die Europäer selten geeint
gesehen hat das habe ich so nicht kommen
gesehen jetzt fragt man sich ja auch
seit Anfang an seit es im Grunde viel
Einschätzungen offenbar gibt von Putin
wie kann das eigentlich passieren
gehen wir mal ein paar Punkte durch da
gibt es eine Einschätzung von Putin
offenbar ich gehe da mit Militär in die
Ukrainer rein und kippe dieses System
und besetze dieses Land in kurzer Zeit
das hat nicht funktioniert
das zweite ist er hat die Ukrainer
offenbar falsch eingeschätzt er hat
gedacht dieses Land wird ihm quasi
direkt huldigen und sich mehr oder
weniger selbst Russland anschließen dann
hat er offenbar ja auch die militärische
Situation falsch eingeschätzt in der
Ukraine er hat auch falsch eingeschätzt
wie die Europäische Union reagiert hat
denn diese enorme Solidarisierung die
wir festgestellt haben war für ihn ja
offenbar überraschend und er hat auch
offenbar falsch eingeschätzt wie die
Amerikaner reagieren wie kommt es zu so
einer Reihe von eklatanten Fehlern
Schätzungen also
das Wichtigste dass man glaube ich
verstehen muss ist dass wir alle die
Zukunft immer aus der Vergangenheit
herleiten also und das ist natürlich die
Zukunft ist nicht das gleiche wie die
Vergangenheit aber in vielen Teilen eben
schon wenn Sie sich anschauen als was
sie gerade beschrieben haben es gab
eigentlich keinen Grund für putinen bis
zum Februar anzunehmen dass die
Situation anders war als in der
Vergangenheit 2014 war die ukrainische
Armee total schwach und er hat halt
unterschätzt wie der stark die sich
verändert hat seit 20 14 die Europäer
haben damals nicht so stark reagiert das
hat er auch unterschätzt
hier tatsächlich also nicht nur Putin
sondern auch die Amerikaner und auch
unsere Geheimdienste haben eigentlich
gedacht dass hier tatsächlich innerhalb
von drei Tagen fallen wird also ich
glaube das war der erste Fehler annehmen
dass alles so ist wie in der
Vergangenheit und dann in die Zukunft
extra polieren aber ich glaube das
zweite und das sage ich auch immer
wieder ich glaube man denkt äh Krieg ist
in erster Linie eine Materialschlacht
und dann zählt man wer hat wie viel
Panzer und wie viel Raketen und wer hat
mehr und der Gewinn aber eigentlich was
im Krieg oft noch entscheidender ist ist
was ich immer sage was man nicht
anfassen kann also Zusammenhalt
Kampfgeist Strategie Überraschungen also
dieses ganze nicht haptische am Krieg
das konnte er so nicht einschätzen dass
die Ukrainer das alles mobilisieren
werden würden und er konnte auch nicht
einschätzen dass es irgendwann auch für
uns eine rote Linie gab also einen
Schritt zu weit und da hat er sich halt
jetzt geirrt das ist er hat ja
strategisch offenbar einige Dinge
versucht
einzusetzen in einer Art von man sagt
das im Zusammenhang einer hybriden
Kriegsführung die zum Beispiel heißt ich
versuche diesen Flüchtlingsstrom aus der
Ukraine zu nutzen um Europa die EU zu
destabilisieren das hat überhaupt nicht
funktioniert im Gegenteil gerade z.B
Polen ist zu einer wirklich enormen
Solidarität aufgestiegen auch andere
europäische Länder haben überhaupt nicht
den Eindruck gemacht das ist ein Problem
mit Flüchtlingen im Augenblick gibt
warum kommt es zu diesen
Fehleinschätzungen die ja offenbar
vieler vielfach psychologische
Fehleinschätzungen sind also es heißt
nicht umsonst internationale Beziehungen
ich glaube wir vergessen immer das sind
Beziehungen zwischen Menschen und das
ist Kommunikation über kulturelle
Grenzen hinweg man hat Einschätzungen
voneinander viel Einschätzungen auch oft
und dann liest man die Welt oder die
andere Seite halt durch seine eigene
Brille durch seine eigenen Interessen
russland hat gewisse Interessen
geopolitische und hat halt gedacht okay
das hat in der Vergangenheit
funktioniert dann wird es auch in der
Zukunft funktionieren also eigentlich so
ein bisschen die gleiche Idee die ich
vorhin schon unterstrichen habe die
größten Überraschungen kommen immer
daher dass man denkt morgen wird genauso
sein wie gestern dazu schreibe ich auch
gerade ein Buch das kommt nächstes Jahr
raus eigentlich wenn man diese Nuss
geknackt hat wenn man verstanden hat
dass man ständig in Frage stellen muss
warum sehe ich die Dinge eigentlich auf
so eine gewisse Weise warum denke ich
dass die Ukraine in drei Tagen
kapitulieren warum denke ich dass die
Europäer nicht reagieren werden
muss man in Frage stellen und dafür
braucht es eine intellektuelle Haltung
von Selbstkritik die es auf jeden Fall
nicht bei Putin gab und die Sachen
unseren Kreisen ganz oft nicht gibt
diese starke Resilienz sagt man jetzt
häufiger also diese Widerstandsfähigkeit
in der
Auseinandersetzung mit dem Angriff bei
den Ukrainern wie lässt sich die
erklären ist das die Verteidigung des
eigenen Landes ist das der
psychologische Hintergrund ich war
letztes Jahr im November in Kiew und das
ist sehr interessant deswegen ist Krieg
ist immer per se von Überraschungen
durchdrungen also wir waren überrascht
im Februar als der Angriff dann kam wir
haben Putin überrascht aber zum Beispiel
selenski ist auch eine sehr interessante
Figur weil er war im November letzten
Kiefer habe ich mir die Umfragewerte
angeschaut er war nicht sehr beliebt als
Präsident und dann kommt so ein also so
ein existenzieller Moment wie ein Krieg
ja der sie nicht nur als Staat in Frage
gestellt sondern auch als Identität geht
denn Russland argumentiert ja auch zum
Teil so die Ukraine ist eigentlich kein
richtiger Staat oder nur zur Hälfte und
und so weiter und so weiter also das ist
so ein Zusammenhalt der entsteht auch
dadurch dass man als Identität
angegriffen wird und ich glaube das
Verstehen glaube ich viele in Europa so
sehr nicht so richtig weil für uns ist
Identität Nationalismus Nationen Gefühl
das ist alles was was klingt für uns als
wäre es aus den 30er Jahren wir haben es
trotzdem aber es schläft sage ich jetzt
mal das Bewusstsein dafür dass wir das
haben
sie haben gerade
Präsidenten angesprochen das ist auch
eine Überraschung tatsächlich waren ja
die Umfragewerte von ihm nicht besonders
gut
er wurde so ein bisschen als Showmaster
abgetan der im Fernsehen zwar eine gute
Rolle spielt aber nicht als Politiker
der ist zu der richtigen Größe geworden
ist auch im Marketing bzw in der
Selbstdarstellung extrem professionell
wie kommt das kommt das exovo aus dem
sozusagen aus dem Nichts heraus ist da
ein Kern bei jemandem vorhanden der dann
plötzlich in einer solchen
Krisensituation sich entwickelt also
auch hier das Beispiel was ich vorhin
genannt habe mit der mit der Zukunft und
der Vergangenheit wir Menschen sind
überraschend schlechterin einzuschätzen
wie wir ins in bestimmten Situationen in
der Zukunft verhalten werden also jetzt
mal als Beispiel zum Beispiel wenn Sie
denken sie werden eine Scheidung
durchleben dann denken Sie vor der
Scheidung Gottes wird alles ganz schlimm
aber eigentlich werden sich dann am Ende
doch ganz gut managen also solche
Krisensituationen wie überschätzen immer
wie schlecht wir uns dann darin
verhalten werden und das heißt wie sie
dann in der Situation eigentlich sind
das können Sie dann nur einschätzen wenn
sie dann plötzlich drin sind also er hat
halt Sachen mobilisieren können die er
als Präsident in Friedenszeiten du nicht
hatte ich denke mal seinen Erfahrungen
Fernsehen und so hat natürlich auch eine
Rolle gespielt aber ich vermute
natürlich auch dass die Amerikaner schon
und auch die Engländer viel
Unterstützung geben jetzt gerade wenn es
um Kommunikation gibt aber ich glaube er
hat auch einfach ein Talent also ich
meine seine Reden sind immer extrem gut
auf das Publikum zugeschnitten an dass
er dich wendet was natürlich bei unseren
Politikern nicht immer so so gut der
Fall ist aber er hat natürlich auch
einen anderen Druck hinter sich so
psychologiestrategie gesprochen auf der
militärischen Ebene waren viele auch
Militärs deutsche Militärs etwa
überrascht was die Ukraine aus wenig
Substanz machen konnten also Beispiel
Drohnen die einfach umgebaut wurden und
dann plötzlich sehr sehr gefährliche
bombenträger waren
wie kommt das zustande ist das
tatsächlich unter diesem Druck auch eine
Fähigkeit militärische Fähigkeiten
weiterzuentwickeln sehr schnell darauf
zu reagieren oder hat die Ukraine da
besondere Vorteile
not macht erfinderisch also einfach die
Tatsache und das ist das was Putin nicht
nicht hat kommen sehen die Tatsache dass
es um was ganz existenzielles ging für
die Ukrainer dass sie natürlich auch
mental 7 Jahre Zeit hatten sich darauf
vorzubereiten dass die Ukraine haben die
ganze Zeit gesagt das wird irgendwann
passieren hat dazu geführt dass sie
extrem kreativ und innovativ mit dem
umgegangen sind was sie zur Verfügung
hatten und deswegen eben was ich auch
vorhin sagte dieses Panzer zählen am
Ende sagt Ihnen das nicht wie wird
dieses Militär sich in Fronteinsatz dann
eigentlich Verhalten das sehen Sie erst
wenn es dann soweit kommt wie gut waren
denn die Ukraine eigentlich auf eine
solche militärische auf solche
militärischen Angriff vorbereitet die ja
Jahre lang schon Logistik
Strategie Taktik gelernt haben unter
anderem von den USA
wir wissen dass die Mandant man geht
davon aus dass so ab 2024 spätestens die
Ukraine in der Lage gewesen wären
militärisch sich die Krim zurückzuholen
und wie die gehen davon aus dass
Russland ist auch wusste und deswegen
diesen Moment gewählt hat auch wenn es
vielleicht trotz Ankündung der
amerikanische ich denke dass das ist
nicht der Grund für den Krieg der Grund
für den Zeitpunkt also warum war es
jetzt letztes Jahr weil sie nicht mehr
länger warten konnten die wussten
irgendwann werden die Ukrainer zu stark
und dann haben wir noch größeres Problem
also ich glaube das ist das eine das
heißt wie gut waren sie vorbereitet sie
waren noch nicht ganz da aber sie waren
auf jeden Fall auf dem Weg dahin sie
haben sich genau auf diese Situation
vorbereitet die dann so eingetreten ist
und das ist auch die erste Symmetrie
zwischen den beiden die Russen haben so
die Situation nicht kommen sehen während
die Ukrainer sich genau auf diese
Situation vorbereitet haben ja lange
drehen dann arbeitet Europa die EU an
einer neuen Sicherheitsarchitektur
wir haben ja jahrelang gedacht das
brauchen wir alles gar nicht mehr das
ist nicht mehr wirklich wichtig wir
haben vor vielen Jahren miteinander
gesprochen in Paris über die
Terrorangriffe das ist auch kein Thema
mehr gewesen man hatte so ein bisschen
den Eindruck dass beruhigt sich alles
vor allen Dingen militärisch konnte man
sich so etwas kaum noch vorstellen
dieser Effekt den wir jetzt spüren in
allen Ländern auch bei allen
Diskussionen die wir in Brüssel hören
wird da eine neue Sicherheitsarchitektur
aufgebaut und macht die in der Form wie
sie das im Augenblick mitbekommen sind
naja sind schon weil wir haben ja keine
andere Wahl also wir haben einen
Nachbarn der ganz offensichtlich
aggressiv vorgeht aggressiv mit mit
militärischen Mitteln versucht Lösungen
herbeizuführen oder Auflösungen
von daher haben wir keine andere Wahl
ich glaube das ist das Wichtigste zu
verstehen die Frage ist wie kommen wir
da jetzt hin
starten wie Frankreich sind nun auch
schon lange sage ich jetzt mal
strategisch militärisch sehr sensibel in
dieser Frage für Deutschland
und Deutschland ist ein ganz wichtiger
Schlüsselfaktor denn wie Deutschland
sich definiert sich neu erfindet in
dieser Situation Stichwort Zeitenwende
wird ausschlaggebend sein für die Form
der dieser Sicherheitsarchitektur wer
dann dabei ist und so weiter und so
weiter also es fühlt sich auch sehr viel
hier in Deutschland ab in den Köpfen
wirklich unser Bürger auch was ist
Deutschland bereit zu geben in der
Hinsicht
mit diesem Begriff Zeitenwende diese
Rede des Bundeskanzler in der er gesagt
hat wir verändern das jetzt wir haben
jetzt etwas erlebt was wir auch alle
nicht so eingeschätzt haben aber jetzt
muss tatsächlich etwas verändert werden
haben wir das richtig angegangen
also ich würde mal sagen typisch deutsch
es wird sehr viel diskutiert und wir
sind immer noch im diskussionstunnel
glaube ich also wir sind dann noch lange
nicht fertig das Geld allein wird nicht
das Problem sein
oder die Lösung sein sondern wie kommt
Deutschland wie kommt Deutschland als
Kultur als Gesellschaft dahin zu
akzeptieren das Krieg eine
nicht eine Normalität aber eine
Möglichkeit wieder ist das ist nicht den
Luxus hat die Bundeswehr als Technisches
Hilfswerk ab und zu mal nach Afrika zu
schicken das im Ernstfall wenn wir
angegriffen werden wir uns auch
verteidigen werden müssen ich glaube das
sind all diese Fragen und ich kriege das
ja auch mit wenn wenn ich einen anderen
Talschluss auch bin dann wenn ich danach
verboten für Nachrichten bekomme es
passiert glaube ich sehr viel einfach in
den Köpfen der Leute aber ich glaube
noch nicht das wäre am Ende angekommen
sind und vielleicht wird es auch noch
ein bisschen länger dauern
da gibt es in Europa
sehr unterschiedliche Ebenen sie sind
deutsch französisch sie haben auch einen
sozialen persönlichen Hintergrund im
Hinblick auf den Zweiten Weltkrieg
ist das der Kern aus dem so etwas
entstehen muss oder müssen wir was zum
Beispiel die Bundeskanzlerin früher
gemacht hat sehr viel mehr die gesamten
Länder mit einbeziehen oder ist es
sinnvoller mit einem Nukleus Deutschland
Frankreich zu beginnen
ich würde sagen sowohl als auch also
ohne Deutschland französische
Kooperation geht gar nichts ähm
die Kriege der letzten und der letzten
Jahre hunderte waren sehr viel
deutsch-französisch geprägt und deswegen
dieser Zusammenhalt wird immer wichtig
sein das sage ich jetzt nicht nur weil
ich auch persönlich daran interessiert
bin und die aktuellen persönlichen
Hintergrund dafür meine Mutter ist aus
Paris meine ihre Eltern sind in
Franzosen gewesen und mein Vater ist
Deutscher seine Eltern wiederum sind in
ÖsterreicherInnen und ein deutscher
gewesen das heißt ich bin ein bisschen
EU sozusagen aber als ich klein war
schon war das extrem war mir schon sehr
bewusst also ich bin 77 geboren mein
deutscher Großvater war in der Wehrmacht
war Pilot mein französischer Großvater
weil der Resistance die haben sich schon
verstanden mehr oder weniger also
sprachlich nicht aber das war es gab
keine Restaurants aber das war mir schon
sehr bewusst es gab einen Krieg zwischen
meinen beiden Familien und es hat Spuren
hinterlassen ja bei den Franzosen immer
das Gefühl ausgeliefert zu sein Angst zu
haben dass sowas noch mal passieren kann
das darf man auch nicht unterschätzen
ich glaube in Deutschland wird oft
unterschätzt wie verletzlich Frankreich
sich gefühlt hat im Jahr 1940 und dass
das bis heute Nachhalt und das ist
eigentlich der Motor hinter diesen
Bedürfnis autark zu sein autonom sich
selbst verteidigen zu können und
umgekehrt auf deutscher Seite natürlich
das Gefühl eben einen riesigen Fehler
gemacht zu haben und nie wieder
aggressiv sein zu dürfen also ich glaube
diese beiden Sachen zusammen das ist
extrem wichtig dass ich das schon ganz
früh erfahren habe und deswegen kommt
wahrscheinlich auch mein Interesse für
Krieg her dass ich das eben Familie
schon erfahren habe warum sind wir da
nicht aus deutscher Sicht sensibel genug
und machen sogar Fehler wie in letzter
Zeit zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich
wo man sagt die Stimmung ist nicht mehr
so gut also wenn sie es beschrieben
haben als sozusagen Nukleus als wichtige
Brücke dann müsste man ja sehr aufpassen
und sehr eng miteinander kooperieren und
auch versuchen die Mentalitäten ein
bisschen zu berücksichtigen aus
deutscher Sicht funktioniert das nicht
immer so richtig französischer Sicht
auch nicht also die aktuelle Situation
würde ich sagen ist das Ergebnis von
zwei größeren Trends der erste ist
brexit mit dem mit dem Ausscheiden der
Briten aus der EU sind die Franzosen die
einzigen eigentlich die eine sage ich
mal ähm
selbstbewusste globale strategische
Mentalität haben
und dagegen Deutschland natürlich halt
in erster Linie immer so als
Wirtschaftsmacht und als ausgleichender
Faktor wahrgenommen wurde und jetzt mit
der Zeitenwende fängt Deutschland an
eben so erste Baby steps in diese
Richtung zu unternehmen und ich glaube
da hat es jetzt angefangen zu krachen in
Gebäck dass sie Franzosen jetzt quasi in
diese so eine Art strategischen also
nicht strategischen sondern mentalen
Positionen sind in der EU wenn es eben
um Außenpolitik geht die fühlen sich
jetzt von Deutschland nicht genug
konsultiert nicht genug wahrgenommen
nicht genug zu Rate gezogen und ich
glaube ich meine am Ende ist es ein
bisschen wie eine Ehe man muss halt
immer wieder von vorne anfangen und
immer wieder die gleichen Debatten haben
ist es nie irgendwie ähm Endpunkt
erreichen und sagt okay jetzt verstehen
wir uns und zwar für immer das ist immer
eine gemeinsame Armee
das ist ja immer die große Frage in der
EU die auch immer wieder kommt ich weiß
nicht ob wir eine gemeinsame Armee
brauchen mit vollgemischten Einheiten
und so weiter aber was wir auf jeden
Fall brauchen ist eine gemeinsame Vision
gemeinsames Beschaffungswesen ich meine
das pooling und Scheren darüber reden
wir schon seit 20 Jahren das übrigens
auch Teil dieses deutsch-französischen
Strahls die Französinnen haben natürlich
eine
[Musik]
Rüstungsindustrie und wollen natürlich
lieber dass die Deutschen bei Ihnen
kaufen als bei den Amerikanern also am
Ende habe ich das Gefühl wir sind in
1963 und dann die gleiche Debatte wie
damals schon so gut und Adenauer aber es
geht immer wieder eigentlich um Daten um
das wie schauen wir gemeinsam auf die
Welt militärische strategisch
außenpolitisch sind wir mehr als
einzelne Staaten sind wir ein Europa in
der Welt oder sind wir halt Frankreich
Deutschland und die 25 anderen in der EU
die ihr eigenes Ding machen aber und du
Google hatten noch den Hintergrund des
Krieges im Kopf das heißt sie wussten
wenn das nicht funktioniert wenn man
nicht sensibel miteinander umgeht
dann führt das wieder zu dem was wir
viele viele Male vorher erlebt haben
nämlich fürchterliche Kriege zwischen
Deutschland und Frankreich und damit ja
auch einer nicht
Zusammenfügung europäischer Staaten
miteinander zu einem Europa was stark
ist und gemeinsame Interessen von tritt
also auch da ist es so aus der
Zukunftsforschung wissen wir dass
Erinnerungen nur eine gewisse
Lebensdauer haben also dass wenn Sie und
ich das nicht mehr direkt erlebt haben
ist es schon schwächer und dann unsere
Kinder und Kindeskinder dann ist es
irgendwann nur noch eine blasse
Erinnerung also die Erinnerung am Leben
zu erhalten ist schwierig und deswegen
immer wieder das persönliche Erleben
wird dann wird dann wichtiger sein ne
ähm aber das ich höre oft in Deutschland
ja Krieg gab es nicht mehr und war für
uns ausgeschlossen aber Deutschland ist
die Außen in Deutschland war einfach
außen politisch immer sehr zurückhaltend
aber für Frankreich hat der Krieg nicht
verlassen aber der Krieg in Algerien
Frankreich war auch sonst überall sehr
sehr engagiert dann natürlich die ter
Attentate 2015 es hat eine extrem tiefe
Wunde gerissen ich glaube für Frankreich
und übrigens auch für viele andere
Staaten war Krieg nie als Option
komplett verschwunden und ich glaube das
ist jetzt gerade es kommt es wieder in
die deutschen Köpfe rein aber die
Franzosen auf der Gegenseite sagen halt
ja aber das war ja nie Weg für uns war
es immer da Militär war aus den
deutschen Köpfen sogar verschwunden sie
engagieren sich militärisch
in der französischen Armee warum
naja weil ich also ich bin
militärsoziologin ich habe meine
Doktorarbeit geschrieben über wie
multi-englisches Militär sich wieder
zusammenfügt nach dem Bürgerkrieg und
ich wollte auch verstehen wie das von
innen ist also was interessantes am
Militär für mich jetzt ist was macht es
mit einer Identität wie Arbeiten Leute
da zusammen und da wollte ich sehen wie
ist das wenn man von innen da eben mit
Teil ist erstens und zweitens
nicht beschäftigt was ich auch gerade
gesagt habe vielleicht auch aus
persönlicher Motivation heraus das
Phänomen Krieg also warum passiert sowas
also eigentlich gerade als deutsche
sollte man sich die Frage immer wieder
stellen und da muss man auch verstehen
was macht das mit der Institution die
hauptsächlich dafür verantwortlich sind
in Deutschland glaube ich hat man
gedacht Krieg ist böse damit sind auch
die Bundeswehr böse und am besten haben
wir nichts mit denen zu Problemen aber
so ist es leider nicht im Gegenteil wir
haben immer mehr Probleme das
Stockholmer Friedensforschungsinstitut
sagt die haben sich quasi verdoppelt in
den letzten Jahren die kriegerischen
aggressiven Auseinandersetzungen jetzt
haben wir auch eine Konstellation in der
Welt die ausgesprochen schwierig zu
beurteilen ist wir haben auch auf der
europäischen Ebene jetzt den Versuch
gehabt in Brüssel stärker mit
asiatischen Ländern zusammen zu arbeiten
weil man vor China so ein bisschen den
Eindruck hat wir brauchen auch dort eine
gewisse ein gewisses Verständnis für das
was wir an Demokratie an liberaler
Demokratie umsetzen wollen
wie gefährlich ist diese Konstellation
weltweit als Strategin wenn sie sich das
anschauen die Konstellation welche
Konstellation man sieht Installation
zwischen einem Europa was sich nicht
wirklich immer einig ist den Amerikanern
die sich stark auf den asiatischen
Bereich inzwischen konzentrieren und
einem Russland dass man sehr schwer
einschätzen kann
es gibt ja einige Bücher die zu dem
Thema auch gerade rausgekommen sind
sowohl von peter Neumann als von Karlo
Marsala im Welt Unordnung
geopolitisch ist es so dass natürlich
wir Konfliktlinien haben also china ist
ein Staat der militärische Ambitionen
haben wird nicht nur wirtschaftlich ich
glaube das hat man ganz lange gedacht
ähm man geht davon aus dass so ab 2027
die Militär schon alleine sein werden
Taiwan zumindest zu belagern ob sie das
dann machen ist wieder eine andere Frage
aber China wird eine Politik haben und
ist auch Russland mittlerweile sehr viel
mehr als früher und auf der anderen
Seite haben wir dann uns und dann haben
wir die Amerikaner und unsere Beziehung
mit den Amerikanern sind auch so ein
bisschen abhängig davon wäre natürlich
im Weißen Haus ist das heißt so per se
ist es ein instabiles Konstrukt das
heißt aber nicht dass es unbedingt in
stabil sein muss es hängt auch ganz
stark von uns ab eben deswegen die
Debatte zum Thema europäische Autonomie
oder so Realität je nachdem
wir haben auch
die Wahl wie wir uns positionieren mit
wem wir uns positionieren ich glaube bis
vor zwei Jahren noch hat man in der EU
gehofft dass man vielleicht mit Kinder
weiter irgendwie noch gemeinsame Sachen
machen kann das kristallisiert sich ein
bisschen heraus dass das so nicht
möglich sein wird auch weil China immer
aggressiver uns gegenüber wird Stichwort
EU die Chinesen spionieren in Brüssel im
großen Stil zum Beispiel also ich glaube
da ich würde nicht sagen dass ein neuer
Kalter Krieg im Kalten Krieg wurde
zwischen den Blöcken nicht gehandelt ist
alles mittlerweile sehr verwoben von
daher könnte man hoffen dass das dem
System mehr Stabilität auch gibt aber
man muss sich glaube ich ein bisschen
verabschieden von dieser Idee das
irgendwie alle sich gut verstehen und
mit allen anderen treiben und es wird
nie wieder Krieg und Konflikt und
auseinandersetzen geben das wird nicht
geben nein aber dieses schreckliche
Aufwachen das bewusst werden einer
Situation am 24 Februar bedeutet das der
Krieg als mit der Politik ist zurück auf
der Weltbühne oder war er überhaupt nie
weg also als eine Expertin Menschen
sagen er war nie weg aber Deutschland
hat einfach nicht dahin geschaut oder
die Deutschen haben nicht dahin geschaut
wo er war also ich meine Krieg in Libyen
Krieg in Syrien ja eine der blutigste
Bürgerkrieg der Geschichte seit 2011
natürlich im Jemen also ich würde nicht
sagen der Krieg der Krieg ist weg
gewesen der Krieg war nur nicht bei uns
ich glaube das ist das ist das harte
Erwachen das zweite ist ich bin kein
hegel-fan aber ich will ihn trotzdem
erwähnen der also Hegel sagt quasi sagte
dass ohne Krieg wäre hören die Leute auf
sich Gedanken darüber zu machen was
eigentlich wichtig ist und dass der
Weltgeist wie er es nannte immer wieder
zu Konflikten führt und mit jedem
Konflikt gibt es Fortschritt das haben
natürlich dann andere Philosophen in
Frage gestellt wie kann z.B der
Holocaust in irgendeiner Form als
Fortschritt bezeichnet werden aber
grundsätzlich glaube ich schon dass die
Debatte die wir jetzt haben uns zurück
wir sind auf was was wichtig ist worum
geht eigentlich im Leben geht es darum
dass ich das nächste iPhone habe und
dass ich nach Tunesien Urlaub fahren
kann und ein Avocado Toast haben oder
geht es um vielleicht ganz essentiellere
Sachen und ich glaube das ist ein ganz
ganz wichtiges Gespräch was wir aktuell
haben was ja auch zum Beispiel die
politische Bedeutung der Demokratie der
liberalen Demokratien anbetrifft wenn
dieser Krieg mal zu Ende ist von dem sie
wahrscheinlich auch schwer einschätzen
können wann das sein könnte man kann ja
da noch nicht immer die gleichen Linien
vergleichen mit anderen kriegen
haben wir die Shows dass das zu einer
Stärkung der Demokratie und zu einem wie
Sie es gerade jetzt beschrieben haben
auch vielleicht hören einer höheren
Sensibilität Krieg gegenüber und
Auseinandersetzungen gegenüber führen
kann ich hoffe schon weil ich denke dass
was wir bis zum 24 Februar geglaubt
haben in Deutschland war dass das eben
morgen wird so sein wie gestern es geht
alles so weiter eigentlich nennt man das
ein a-historisches Geschichtsverständnis
also alles geht immer weiter weiter
weiter
aber jetzt haben wir festgestellt Krieg
ist eine Möglichkeit und jetzt wissen
wir auch Demokratie verlieren ist auch
eine Möglichkeit wir sehen es überall
mit populistischen Parteien Demokratie
war eigentlich so bis die frühen 2000er
auf dem Vormarsch also das war das
politische Modell was ist überall mehr
und mehr gab jetzt fängt das an in die
andere Richtung zu gehen also auch die
Demokratie ist nichts was es einfach so
für immer geben wird wir müssen immer
wieder dafür kämpfen und ich glaube das
hat uns der Krieg gelernt dass nichts
ist je einfach aki ist nie für immer da
man muss sich immer wieder dafür
einsetzen
wie sehr sind sie persönlich betroffen
von dem Krieg
wir sind ja jetzt als Wissenschaftlerin
jemand der sich damit auseinandersetzt
das ist ein unglaublich spannendes
Strategie Thema ein militärthema aber
was sozusagen hat sich bei ihnen
vielleicht auch in der Weltsicht
geändert
dass wir diese Debatte überhaupt haben
finde ich super aber es überrascht mich
auch also weil ich und auch andere haben
schon seit Jahren immer wieder versucht
Deutschland dahin zu bringen dass es
begreift dass die Welt eben nicht
Glücksbärchi Paradies ist und das alles
immer super sein wird und das war extrem
schwer also das ist die eine Komponente
natürlich was in der Ukraine selber
passiert nicht gerade auch zweimal ist
ist furchtbar und und
Menschenleben werden zerrissen zerstört
und für mich ist es dann manchmal
schwierig wirklich den Blick auf der
strategischen Ebene zu behalten und das
große Ganze zu sehen und sich nicht
durch Einzel Schicksale jetzt davon
ablenken zu lassen das richtige Wort
aber das klingt ein bisschen herzlos
aber das ist für mich eine
Herausforderung aber wenn ich ihn noch
ähm was sagen sie meinten sie wissen
auch nicht wann der Krieg zu Ende geht
ich glaube worauf es einstellen müssen
ist ein provisorisches Ende irgendwann
nächstes Jahr wird vielleicht zu einer
Art Waffenstillstand kommen aber das
wird nicht das Ende des Krieges sein per
se sondern dann wird der Konfl einfach
weiter aufgeschoben in die Zukunft also
das ist auch mit dem Grund warum ich
sage man muss sich darauf einstellen
dass es jetzt das neue normal selbst
wenn die Waffen schweigen wir werden
nicht zu 23 Februar 21 zurückkehren das
kann man eigentlich nur die Hoffnung
haben dass Menschen die ja lernfähig
sind obwohl man manchmal Zweifel daran
hat vielleicht aus dem was da passiert
ist lernen und auch die Politiker daraus
lernen und wir alle daraus lernen woraus
gab ganz herzlichen Dank dass Sie bei
mir waren und auch ganz herzlichen Dank
an sie Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer der
Sendung die früher noch Dialog hieß und
jetzt Phönix persönlich heißt das ist
meine letzte Sendung gewesen ich habe
sie sehr sehr gerne gemacht und über
zehn Jahre unglaublich viele spannende
Gäste gehabt und ich bedanke mich vor
allen Dingen bei Ihnen für Ihr Interesse
danke schön
[Musik]